let's continue with the story of Pete's
mutual fund so let's say that a year
goes by and then even after paying Pete
the one percent so we had five hundred
dollars of assets under management
this whole assets under management a
year later goes to let's say it goes to
like I mentioned at the end of the last
video $1,000 so Pete either is really
good or really lucky or a little bit of
both so it goes to $1,000 so let me draw
it like this
so now it is at $1,000 and it still has
the same five investors here and I'm
lucky enough to be one of them so here's
the five investors let me draw the share
so there's one two three four five
shares now each of these shares that
well the thousand dollars is called the
nav or the net asset value so let me
give you give you that piece of
terminology just means net asset value
and so there's an nav per share the nav
per share right over here is $200 I just
took the total nav and I just divided it
by the shares and what's special about
an open-ended mutual fund is that the
close or at the end of every day either
new shares can be removed from the fund
or could be created before the fund so
in the first video I showed how I wanted
to buy into the fund so I bought a share
and that increased the nav and it also
increased the number of shares he had to
create a share for me to buy he didn't
so he didn't sell me a share that
already existed so you could imagine
after this type of performance more
people would want to buy shares so now
they would have to buy in to make things
fair at $200 per share because that's
the current nav per share so let's say
that five more people want to buy in at
$200 per share so what Pete would do or
what this mutual fund it's not Pete
really it's the corporation it would
create five new shares so 1 2 3 4 5
there's only there's only one person
that day it would create one share that
day if there were 10 people that day it
would create 10 shares that day and it
could keep doing this and the nav of
each of these are $200 so it gives these
shares to each of these people and they
have to
contribute $200 so essentially it puts
another $1,000 into the pool that Pete
can now manage and so now he's met the
total nav for the fund is $2,000 now and
Pete will get his 1% management fee off
of this entire $2,000 now let's say that
we fast forward a little bit we fast
forward a little bit to lets say Pete
starts having a not-so-good year so
let's say we fast forward a year past
that and Pete's Pete has a minus a
negative 10% return so if you started at
$2,000 and that's when you include
taking his management fee out you start
at $2,000 you lose 10% in one year so it
goes down to $1,800 let me do this in a
new color so now he's at $1,800 and it's
not completely a drawn to scale but
hopefully you get the idea so now he is
at $1,800 1800 1800 dollars but you
still have a total of 10 shares you
still have total of 10 shares so let me
draw try to do my best to draw the 10
shares so I have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
these should be of equal size and now
the nav per share nav per share is going
to be 1,800 divided by 10 or 180 dollars
and let's say that I get a little bit
freaked out by this recent performance
and I have some other commitments with
my money so I say Pete you need to buy
this my share back for me so what Pete
does is he would give me back $180 so
the total nav would be would lose 180
dollars so would go down $180 so we
would take this out of it 1,800 minus
180 is 1620 so now it is 1620 and they
would buy back a share from me so they
would cancel one of the shares but
notice the nav per share does not change
by me redeeming my share it does not
change what happens to everyone else now
you have 1620 divided by 9 shares that
should still get you to be
180 dollars per share if I did my math
right so 1800 divided by minus 180 gets
you 1620 it should still be one eight
hundred and eighty dollars per share but
this is the nature of an open-ended fund
you can keep creating shares and selling
them to the public to raise more money
or when someone wants their money back
you essentially buy the share back from
them give them their money when you buy
it back and you remove that share so an
open-ended fund really at the close of
every trading day can keep growing or
shrinking it can keep adding more and
more investors or their investors can
take their money back what's difficult
about this from the fund managers point
of view is that they have to manage this
they have to manage this constant buying
and selling with the public they have to
manage the paperwork and if you think
about it they can't have all of their
money invested in in relatively illiquid
assets or even in regular stocks they
have to keep some amount of their money
and it's usually like three to five
percent they have to keep some of this
2,000 dollars before he lost my money
they have to keep some of it in cash and
from an investor's point of view they
would say well if I'm good at investing
I shouldn't I should try to minimize the
amount of cash that I have because I'm
not getting a return on cash but because
it's open-ended because investors might
come by and say hey I want my money you
have to have a little bit of cash on it
as part of the asset pool in order to be
able to buy people's shares back